you really are such a dynamic and
powerful actress and we
really got to see that shine in episode
four of season
eight my uncle didn't do anything wrong
you have to stop what you're doing you
don't understand
you don't my uncle is one of the finest
mounties
he's honest and brave and and impeccable
disaster thornton take me back to that
scene
what was going through your mind as you
were there
crying trying to plead on behalf of your
uncle
i think ally is very protective of uncle
nathan so i tried to put myself
in her shoes and feel like what it would
feel like if
one of my own family members or even
kevin because he's kind of like
my family member if that would actually
happen
and i was just bawling at the time i
snot everywhere i felt it in the moment
and i was just talking all these guys in
this room and i could see it on kevin's
face and i was like okay
this is it this is it's working it's a
pivotal moment
my uncle's more like my father
he's all i have please
how did you get into that mindset of
being able to just have the tears stream
down your face is there a secret
i found this really sad tick tock page
and i just watched all these tick talks
and
it was like military people coming home
and like grandparents like together
and i just started crying from it i was
like oh my gosh this is so sad
but then i after i got this tears going
i put myself in ally's shoes and the
acting
came through that strategy obviously is
working because you had me
in a puddle of tears on my couch as i
was watching it kevin yeah
i'm gonna wait i'm gonna i'm gonna have
to get that link can you send me the
link
so yeah move before okay kevin of course
you're in that scene
and you're sitting in the room and
you're watching jada as she
delivers this really powerful monologue
what's going through your mind
she got me you know like i was just
welling up kind of at the idea that
because what i was seeing was
you know a person who was scared that
like their
person was gonna be taken away from them
and
like nathan is all ali has like her mom
passed away
and we know what happened with her dad
like nathan is
her world for that episode to kind of be
so stuffy about you know like
you know bill is a lawyer and then all
this courtroom dialect
and then for you know uh just a little
girl to run in and tears just be like
just don't
take my dad away from me or my you know
my my guy away from me
because like he's all i have and he's a
good person and you guys are stupid you
can't see that and it just
for nathan and for me too just kind of
watch that it gets you because
you don't realize the effect you have on
somebody else and you don't realize how
important you are to somebody else's
world
and this was such a big thing that
brought nathan and ali together
it is my recommendation to this council
that no further action be taken in this
matter
[Music]
this is kind of the catalyst and and a
big movement for nathan like
going full speed into making their
relationship permanent a way of a father
and a daughter kind of thing
this was kind of the moment that he's
like i that he sees how much he actually
does mean to ali you know
because i think up until this you know
up until then not that he didn't love
her and i didn't
really care about her but but it was you
know like i'm looking after my sister's
daughter i'm going to her i'm going to
look after her and she's family but like
at this moment he's like
oh this is more than just that like this
you know i'm her world and she's my
world and yeah
i know jada was obviously crying in that
scene kevin were you
actually crying in that scene i was
watering up i wasn't crying but i mean
just like
i mean she was yeah it was moving
jada for you playing ally who has you
know such a tight-knit relationship with
her uncle
how does it feel to see your uncle
really being put through the ringer this
season
i think it's a little hard for her
because she just wants
so bad for him to be happy and i think
she really is trying to push something
with him so he doesn't feel like
he's alone in that aspect and
i just really think she wants what's
best for him and she thinks that
elizabeth
is what's best for him once the parties
find out they'll see
why everything happened how it did
is it safe to assume jada that you're on
team nathan
yes i like chris at all i'm sorry
if chris is watching this i'm sorry but
it's super here kind of hard to
be on his side when like i'm attached to
nathan's character so i'm